on la voit là elle est là omniprésente
ici la mérule la voici bien incrustée
dans les fondations du temple
Saint-Martin en cause trop d'humidité
peu de lumière cette sport peut dormir
dans les murs pendant des siècles et
détériorer tout un bâtiment elle part
toujours d'un point précis elle se
développe et elle fructifie et elle
continue en fait à dégrader les bois
jusqu'à en fait il rendre complètement
friable on le voit tout ce qui est ici
en fait ça a été complètement délité par
par la mirule et le bois n'a plus de
fibre donc il se casse en fait très
facilement et quand on le prend en main
en fait on le transforme en poussière
prochaine étape penser à l'éradiquer on
va challumer le sol injecter du
fongicide percer les murs selon les
préconisations de traitement en vigueur
c'estàdire tous les 25 cm au 2 tiers du
mur on va mettre des injecteurs et on va
remplir avec du fongici des sommes
supplémentaires dont la paroiss se
serait bien passé comme en 2014 lors de
la précédente prolifération du
champignon ils appellent à la solidarité
les panneaux en bas c'est ceux qui sont
donc pas traités qui vont avoir c'est
c'est c'est triste c'est dommage ENF
c'est comme ça et c'est qui était de ce
côté-ci qui était de ce côté-ci mais qui
ont l'air un peu moins abîmés que ceux
qui étaient de l'autre côté chantier qui
au départ devait coûter à peu près 3
millions de va nous coûter un peu plus
de 4 millions résultat le plus vieux
temple encore en activité en France ne
pourra pas rouvrir au printemps alors
que mon bellliard vient d'être sacrée
capitale française de la culture pour
l'année